e arrivato il momento di entrare nel
mondo di under the hill signori io non
ho mai mai giocato ad under tail è una
mia mancanza perché i giochi in 8 bit
non mi hanno mai attirato più di tanto
quindi andate proprio quando lo vedevo
dice non l'ho mai giocato
mea culpa perché so che è un gioco della
madonna quindi io non ho giocato ad un
gioco della madonna
però siccome under the hill è molto
conosciuto non voglio iniziare con under
ti voglio iniziare con delta room o del
tar un e che ancora non capì come si
dice che è un gioco fatto allo stesso
creatore di under the hill non è
necessario aver giocato andartene per
giocare lettera un quindi io entrerò nel
mondo di under the hill attraverso del
tar un farò questa serie su del the room
quindi voi che avete giocato ad andar te
non mi spoilerato e una mazza se non vi
ammazzo io non ho idea di come sia fatto
under the cia non ho idea di che cosa tu
debba fare nel gioco quindi non ho idea
di che cosa tu debba far in del tar
quando finirò del tar un vedrò se
giocare per la prima volta nella mia
vita
under the hill sei qui e si professa non
mi vedi che sto qua siamo noi
connessi specchi controllo ci si cielo
hifi secolo stai calmo che è successo un
cuore eccellente davvero eccellente
va beh meno male che contento dovremmo
cominciare è ben si sarebbe anche ora il
partito seleziona la testa che
preferisci la testa a il mio personaggio
pelato che brutto
questa selezione al corso che preferisci
nostro tutti uguali cala felpa dai caf
elpa e le mani tonde seleziona le gambe
che preferisci
sono tutte uguali è questa noi prendiamo
questo è il tuo corpo lo accetti beh
l'ho fatto io
qual è il suo cibo preferito il suo cibo
preferito e dolci il tuo tipo di sangue
preferito ma che ne so boh
ab il colore che piace di più è il rosso
per favore dagli un gift xf tipo regala
gentilezza
come ti senti riguardo la tua creazione
la parentesi tranquillo non ti sentirai
aveva schiva brutta non l'ho fatta io
quindi l'oblazione speranza speranzoso
hai risposto onestamente sì sì sì che è
un quiz cos'è dai un nome al tuo
vessillo per una volta nella vita
chiamiamoci normalmente per una volta
nella vita in un gioco mi chiamo
normalmente visto che un gioco serio
in teoria abbiamo chiamato fa vj sit in
crea la prima volta cosa mio nickname
normali in un giorno e per quanto
riguarda il creatore e sempre fa vincere
mi chiama non è che si chiama vengono è
diverso lo rimettiamo lori grazie per il
tuo tempo ma è grazie a te fico la tua
tua meravigliosa creazione ok che è
successo ora sarà distrutta un'ora e
mezza nessuno può scegliere chi è in
questo mondo il tuo nome è chris cos'è
sta roba ha chiesto una mucca che parla
chissà se non ti svegli fareitalia
scuola ma c'è una mucca che mi sta
parlando che esattamente cosa sta
ti aspetterò fuori d'accordo ci sono io
il personaggio creato da c'è una mucca
che mi ha parlato posso muovermi allora
che faccio esco ma che bella questa casa
ma mamma ti posso chiamare così c'è
anche il riflesso nello specchio
bellissimo chris eccoti qua
dovremo ancora farcela dobbiamo dare a
scuola vai mamma mucca il sapere food
day two days ma sì più o meno a zona
dall'università ok ma ma entro io
tranquilla acciaio nove premi prima
tenera questa scena a sono entrato io
baccheschi c'è un serpente in classe v o
chris quindi guardati intorno e trova un
compagno va bene va bene adesso io vado
sul serpente subito guarda quanto guarda
avanti gang sterzo serpente chi è questo
susy è una tipa cosa dovrebbe essere una
specie di cavallo sono in ritardo o no
no no stavamo soltanto è cercando i
compagni per il prossimo il gruppo
progetto di gruppo e sugli sarai con
chris fantastico e vitalità che già
stati zero grazie
che classe strana scotta susy ciò che fa
cosa che si è mangiata chris non hai
visto niente vero non puoi neanche
parlare sia effettivamente non parlo mai
com'è possibile
oh mio dio mio dio ei
se però lascia che ti dica un segreto
la madonna le persone silenziose mi
stanno sul pensi che solo perché tu non
dici nulla io non posso esattamente
sapere a che cosa stai pensando è finita
ho visto susy mangiare tutto il gol che
sarebbe era l'ultima sua possibilità ora
finalmente lei sarà espulsa
andiamo crisi non sembrare scioccato lo
sai che è vero
sembra uno spreco di tempo rimanere
esposti solo x men per aver mangiato uno
snack quindi chris perché non dovrei
essere espulsa super qualche vera
carneficina
chris come ti senti per quanto riguarda
perdere la tua faccia
no no no no no no no avevi una buona
madre sarebbe un peccato farle
seppellire il proprio figlio andiamo a
prendere più chat non so se poi torniamo
in classe come poi tu farai il progetto
mi ha chiesto che cosa ne pensi va bene
non va bene però poi mi ha detto subito
non c'è bisogno di che tu risponde le
tue scelte non contano professore mi ha
quasi mangiato la faccia questa
d'accordo c'è un
armadio tube che peccato stavamo giusto
iniziando a divertirci che è successo ei
chris sono io è davvero buio là dentro e
l'armadio tipo e narnia e narnia vabbè
andremo insieme
va bene vedi perché se così spaventato
non c'è niente va dentro trova nei
vecchi pezzi carta troviamo un
interruttore seal fis vuole il folk
pensi a non so cosa da mangiare
e se la può prendere da solo dividiamo
vediamoci no ai a quota portaci fuori la
cosa divertente è che proprio con questa
faccia da culo dovevo rimanere chiuso
dentro allarmati va beh lasciateci il
pavimento st
[Musica]
cos'è sono io sono io a volte la vedi
sbrilluccica re la luce che solo tu puoi
vedere ma secondariamente la raggiungi è
a essere per salvare la partita va bene
che figata
quindi è più o meno fatto bisogna anche
under tail sembrano facce queste cose
qui c'è chi ansia
ho visto uno che correrò sono io scemo
c'è c'è uno nudo che corre ei stai
lontano che chris c'è qualcuno lassù che
ci sta salutando hai una minima idea di
che cosa voglia c'è qualcuno eccolo
quello nero di prima ciò ha lanciato due
di picche non intende questo quando si
dice due di picche cori chris va bene
corri corri ci lancia ip che ha come
quando provi a rimorchiare una ragazza
il due di picche volano che è una
meraviglia vai vai vai dove serve una
tipa da friends on
perché bravo che sono schivato tutto
fenomeno ok sono schiantato al suolo ma
deve tanto a posto tranquillo a non sei
morto fantastico hai un'idea di che cosa
sia questo posto ma no magari quindi
cosa vuoi che faccia vado in giro c'è
una porta è chiusa
faccio un oggetto in fronte a te c'è un
castello che si erge davanti alla città
vuota
diamo al castello andiamo famosa il
castello in castello perché c'è un
castello dentro un armadio benvenuti
eroi
chi è non state all'erta io non sono
vostro nemico per favore venite avanti
entrambi beh sembri veramente un
ricovero di senatore
benvenuti sono il principe di questo
regno il regno dell'oscurità scritto
proprio lei col font quello che chris
susy sai già il nostro nome bravo c'è
una leggenda in questo posto una
leggenda che un giorno due errori della
luce saranno una leggenda che dice che
un giorno due eroi della luce
arriveranno ed esaudiranno un'antica
profezia che è stata tramandata nel
tempo non lo so
io andrò a trovare una strada per uscire
su si aspetta
cosa è successo gli eroi sono già
scappati e non sapevano neanche che io
fossi qui
mio padre mi rieleggerà a figlio del
diavolo 6
io sono il ragazzo cattivo quello
cattivo
va bene sappiamo entrambi che andrete ad
est è l'unica via per per tornare a casa
ma io lancer non vi lascerò andare a ci
stiamo allenando seriamente il
combattimento tipo final fantasy
defender spar item art fight lancer evo
e allora aspettare prova a menarlo di
nuovo comunissima ciò fatta leva molto
di più susy mi piace essere arca vacca
non faccio in tempo a tortura che mi
mena ma perché mena solo mehman a susy
magari non so che si gioca non ho mai
giocato dall under the quindi non lo
sapevo perdonatemi hai vinto 0
esperienza 34 soldi state bene ragazzi è
più o meno lasciatemi introdurre un po
meglio io sono gesù poi per tirare giù
con l'acqua il cappuccio d'accordo è già
per questioni di sicurezza ri mettitelo
ciao a tutti io sono raoul 6 chris susy
fantastico conoscermi
sono certo che diventeremo buoni amici è
il miglior modo per andare via e andare
ad est vero sì questo è la e dove
dovremmo ok ho capito e va da sola
ci vediamo a scuola crif ma le estere
innanzitutto a destra il dovresti andare
proprio a destra primo secondo
come pensi di uscire spero che saremo
degli ottimi amici cris
prima a trovare susy deve essere andata
a sud est
va bene gli avanti allora è meglio che
non ha le braccia e c'è un cuore sul
petto sto tizio a me chris quando
passeremo quella porta la nostra
avventura inizierà davvero un viaggio
esattamente come descritto nella
professi profezia tramandata makris
credo che le nostre scelte saranno
importanti questo mondo pieno di persone
gentili chris come le tratteremo farà la
differenza
quindi facciamo del nostro meglio di per
proseguire senza combattere
se riusciamo a farlo facciamo del nostro
meglio va bene va bene del tar plasmato
da bar
salviamo la porta si è chiusa dietro di
voi e la lettura sta veramente iniziando
dopo che bel posto che belli sti alberi
ma diventa anche il nome della canzone
nemici davanti morirete firmato
l'anziano ma mi hai detto lancer ma non
è vero ma no no è la mia mi ha attaccato
lui ma proviamo a proviamo ad
abbracciarlo convinsi come vedere
spero non lo di non lo attaccare non
attaccare gli spazi se n'è andato ok
perfetto potevamo non coprì possiamo
anche non combattere però penso che non
vada bene per tutti
djavan c'è l'orologio hai un enigma
clock check the clock nord del tu sull
ipad controllano logio per risolvere il
puzzle devi fare in fretta
va bene ragazzi io per oggi concludo qua
il primo episodio se under tela e la
metà bello di questo lo giocherò appena
finito delta non veramente fighissimo
fighissimo canzoni trama bellissimo
spero mi sia piaciuto ragazzi come
argomento mi piace anche vari social
come la descrizione se non sei dovresti
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo visto bene
[Musica]